so what did you actually learn making
the first season that you wanted to take
with you to the second season
you know
that harry the kid the character of
harry as the alien he has a
he has
a wild range
in emotion um you know he's he's
somewhat stoic as a character his his
emotions especially in the beginning
uh he didn't have them and then he
starts to develop them as he stays on
earth longer and that becomes a problem
in the second season he's getting too
many emotions he's
can't deal with them all
uh
i learned
in season one during the human sex scene
uh i where i have sex with a human
person um
harry's wife that
it you the humor of it can be somewhat
broad uh
when harry is involved in this
i make a crazy sound in the conclusion
of that act
and i think one of my eyes crosses in
and uh i'm a slobber on myself and i
and yet the world of resident amy can
contain it it was very big but the world
doesn't even continue
it didn't cross a line into oh i went
too far so i learned in the first season
possibly unfortunately
that i could go really big and it and it
could be contained
uh so there are moments within i guess
this season where the comedy uh if it
allows for something that
can be filled a moment that can be
filled to the top i'll i'll possibly
go the distance there
what was you
listen i i think you're great on the
show
this series only works because of your
ability to play this character um it's
really everything the uh what was your
reaction though when you found out that
the first season's ten episodes and
chris told me the second season is 16.
so were you sort of like wait what or
were you like oh let's do it
yeah i was let's do it i i love the idea
of a 10 episode
uh season i just like those to watch
them you know i just like i love i love
little small story lines and you get you
get those pieces and then as actors it's
a new thing
um to have these types of series where
you can just have a smaller even 16 as a
small
order from what it used to be when i
first started out they were 23.
20 22 23.
um
yeah and that just seems bad seems like
madness now uh so 16 is bigger i was
excited about getting to do more with
everybody and do more story wise um
i like how we're splitting it up
we're gonna have the first ten
uh and then the last six we're gonna
have a little break so
uh
it'll we won't be off the air for so
long and i'm
i'm excited about that i like that idea
because there's just such a long period
of break that becomes you know that
happens
um for fans of the series what are you
allowed to tease about season two
i'm an alien i want to just get that out
there right off the bat
i am playing
um
uh
i want that harry is dealing with
emotions this season and it's something
that he dealt with right at the end of
last season
but
uh it's a it's a bigger problem
he has an identity crisis uh he's
becoming more and more human and that's
that's offensive to him uh that's not
who he is it's he came here to kill all
the humans and now he's caught up in
this whole
humanity and it's not okay
so he's doing his best to hold on to his
who he is and asking all those questions
if you ask us about who am i
but part of that of getting human
emotions because he is like a child
he gets them a lot like children
get them or feel them he feels them very
intensely he feels them
all of a sudden he's unable to
he needs to figure
how to
suppress them and control them and uh so
for comedy sake that's a there's a lot
of fun to be had
with someone who's
out of control in that way this season
uh
as well as
still not being the most physically
uh deft individual on the planet
you have done you've done so many things
in your career already uh but is it does
it get any easier when you're on set
talking to a fish tank where there's an
octopus that's supposed to be in the
tank but in the tank there's nothing so
i'm just curious as an actor does it
ever get
like is it still weird to talk to a fish
tank when no one is there or have you
sort of just gotten used to it now
i have gotten used to it
uh
yeah you just get used to it
sometimes you're talking to a tennis
ball sometimes you are the tennis ball
that's that's the
experience uh
i although this season with the octopus
specifically
uh in the first episodes i don't think
we had the actual octopus but now we
have one made of silicone that looks
very much like the octopus
uh
so it's it's a combination of cgi and
practical
and when i am talking to nathan phillips
octopus we have nathan's voice being
piped in
and there's puppeteers puppeteering
so
it's it's a puppet naked philly and on
set and he's an octopus
so that is
that's just a beautiful that's that's
beautiful that's what i signed up when i
was a kid
and wanted to do
theater and make believe that's the kind
of thing i wanted to do was have
conversations with
pretend octopus people
puppets
like have have have a conversation with
your friend who's also a puppet and an
obstacle
at the same time
and that's what we get to do
my last question for you i am a huge fan
of david lowry and um i know you worked
with him i'm just curious if you could
talk about getting to work with him on
that project something i'm so looking
forward to
i
i enjoyed that so much
um
i have so much respect for david
uh
when you get into a world you know where
there is so much cgi you get into these
worlds where there's fantasy and
make-believe and there is so much cgi
that you're acting with tennis balls
like we were talking about and
you're doing a lot of the pretending in
your brain um
he was he created a world where they
built a ship they built the entire ship
and it was on this thing that rocked it
it was
there was a skull island in the whole it
looked like we were an amusement park um
it was such an exciting set to be on
there were kids everywhere
and they all had ideas and it was all
there was moments of mayhem and they
would just be like okay here we got it
he's just the most chill
leader in the middle of all of this and
i
i just had such respect for him i had a
blast i have a small part to play i you
know i play mr dowling i'm the guy at
the beginning who says wendy you've got
to grow up and then [ __ ] yeah i'm like
oh you've grown up and so it's kind of
my gig because i just sort of bookend
thing but uh i so enjoyed the at the
time i was there
you know i i wish i could have uh had
more time on that step
and that's
i don't say that a lot
you're like god i wish i'd go to work
more i wish i could have gone to work
more i really enjoyed the kids were
amazing that the young people were
mind-boggling
how intelligent and uh
thoughtful they were and he was a
perfect leader
that's great
i honestly can't wait but listen man i
really enjoy your work in this uh and i
just want to say thank you so much for
giving me your time today
thanks man i appreciate it thank you
cool have a great day
cheers you too